il fallait pas louper et hier dans tpm
percevez charlize theron et seth rogen
pour le film séduit moi si tu peux alors
comme ils sont américains on a fait
appel à des traducteurs qui était très
sympa qui d'ailleurs les deux jolies les
traducteurs et après quelques sorties
something j'ai demandé donc le
traducteur de venir en plateau à un
moment où j'ai voulu faire un bisou
amical à la traductrice que je la
sentais un petit peu stressé visiblement
j'avais pas compris parce que je suis
pas le meilleur en anglais elle m'avait
dit un truc j'ai pas bien compris en
fait mais ça n'a pas trop plu à charlize
theron sa saison droit mais en fait
aujourd'hui il ya eu des vingtaines et
les vingtaine d'articles dessus je vais
vous dire tous les articles et le
problème que j'ai avec tous les
journalistes ont repris ce que
j'appelais nadia la traductrice et je
vais vous dire ce qu'elle a dit nadia la
traductrice et ce qu'elle vous dit voilà
ce qu'elle m'a dit voilà et canadien
voilà je vous dis qui a été formidable à
la poubelle avec elle a cru qu'elle
avait flingué un peu lassé compte unique
pas du tout au contraire je pense
qu'elle l'a sauvé regardez est ce que
vous pouvez dire à 7 et à charlize que
je dois envoyer la pub parce que je dois
faire rentrer un petit peu d'argent à
vous l'êtes vous mettre derrière sommes
alors mettez-vous de rien mais on
aimerait que les gens
est ce qu'on peut parler pour le public
aussi
c'est non nadia alors elle est
franchement
[Rires]
elle a donc charlize theron louis gill
alors mon tant que téléspectateur
j'étais pas là j'ai trouvé deux shows
d'abord j'ai trouvé charlize theron très
désagréable oui serait fermée alors je
vous le dis avec matthieu delormeau lieu
de demander une photo à la fin de
l'émission a fait non à aftu go vous
êtes bien a tellement les humeurs et
j'étais très jeune et au retard 10 et
aux retards de 20 minutes mais bon ok
déshabillez vous lis je faillis rebond
maintenant pirée chez eux
oui j'ai trouvé que c'était très
méprisant pour le téléspectateur parce
qu'elle vient faire sa promo elle donne
rien mais ce statut là dessus sur 7
cette remarque parce que moi j'ai pas
bien compris et c'est vrai que moi je le
trouve alors christine parce que ça nous
moi j'ai tué là je n'ai pas très bien
compris non plus je pense que nous on
était là on n'a pas tous compris à la
farine est premièrement deuxième
remarque c'est que aux états unis
embrasser c'est peut être choquant et en
france pas du tout fait pour durcir leur
marque dans son film je crois qu'une
scène de masturbation et on va falloir
qu'on m'explique et 4e roma et vous avez
commencé l'émission vous avez embrassé
momo non bien sûr de la même façon bah
oui mais c'est vrai exactement mais momo
alors je vous le dis moi moi le seul
problème que j'ai je vais vous dire la
vérité charlize theron et pense qu'elle
veut c'est derrière tous les
journalistes
aujourd'hui on était vraiment vous savez
dans les trucs vraiment les des titres
voilà que vous avez sur votre smartphone
on voit la tendance alors je vous dis
les titres de l'express d'aider encore
n'importe quoi demander avant charlize
theron apprend le consentement hacienda
normes ils ont fait tous des titres
incroyables of une tonne post charlize
theron re4 cyril hanouna dans tpm paix à
cause d'un baiser après un baiser volé
charlize theron record recadre sirena
sur le consentement europe 1 il ferait
mieux de s'occuper de leur audience
voilà demandé avant charlize theron
apprend le consentement donc charlize
theron recadre sèchement sirène venait
en direct dans tpm psk pas un
journaliste qui vit un moment
pourquoi je vais reprendre ça est-ce que
je vais pas le prendre reprendre avec un
petit peu d'objectifs bien ce n'est pas
la clé rien alors moi ce que j'ai fait
c'est que moi quand je fais un truc qui
aiment bien savoir si j'ai blessé des
gens pas échappé nadia la traductrice et
jeudi nadia est ce que tu as eu un
problème avec la seconde hier à mahdia
oui j'ai un problème parce que je pense
que je t'ai flinguer la séquence qu'on
n'entendait pas bien aux régies ça je
lui ai dit mais à nadia jeux mac
flinguer rien du tout vous avez été très
drôle
les deux interprètes vraiment ils ont
été très drôle heureusement qu'ils
étaient là et elle me dit
le bisou je rencontrais rahmani voilà je
dis bon je pique un peu mais sinon ça va
et elle m'a dit le seul truc qui m'a
gêné c'est les reprises partout elle me
dit ce qui m'a gêné c'est nous tous ces
journalistes qui ont repris et donc il
ya plein de gens qui m'appellent kiki
son pote qui ont pas vu la séquence
c'est un petit peu ce qui se passe
autour de tpb quand ils font des titres
de fou on croit toujours qu'il se passe
des trucs de fou sur l'émission donc les
mecs disent tu abuses s'est passé sur
tpb bahia juste un mec qui essaie de m
voilà en qui sait qu'ils essaient de
mettre en confiance et qui essaient de
voile à servir la traductrice j'aurais
fait pareil avec n'importe qui et donc
voilà et est donc derrière elle me dit
ce qui m'a gêné c'est que tout le monde
m'appelle en dix ans mais ça va accepter
kim et moi ça va très bien voilà c'est
juste les journalistes qui ont repris et
toutes les reprises l'ont gêné rtl
pareil a repris touche pas à mon poste
charlize theron rocade tirer mais après
un baiser il ferait mieux de s'occuper
de leur audience et aussi qu'ils sont
dégueulasses épanouie mais je vous dis
moi oui mais c'est pas vous mais je le
dis voilà donc voilà si tout le monde
les z'arts up bien entendu voilà tout le
monde donc aaa a mis ça y'a pas vous
êtes il ya des journalistes autour de la
table il y en a pas un qui se dira
moment je vais je vais jouer je parlais
qu'objective it et de cette séquence
avec gervais a demandé aux
téléspectateurs c'est ça les a choqués
ou pas cette séquence voilà vous demande
d'y voir surtout strauss kahn à qui vous
a appelés pour nous demander de vous et
de votre taxe d'habitation je vous dis
je parle à personne si elle m'a dit
qu'elle avait reçu plein d'appels de
journalistes qui voulaient mettre de
l'huile solaire j'ai répondu à personne
ils ont soulevé toute la journée à
m'appeler voilages et valérie non mais
ce qui aurait fait ce qui aurait été
tout à fait honnête intellectuellement
c'était de recontextualiser et
d'expliquer que c'est un phénomène très
américain qu'on ne se fait pas la bise
de façon facile et qu'on s'embrasse pas
aux états unis comme on s'impatiente et
il a sauvé était évidemment un sujet
qu'on aurait pu aborder et paf
mais si je vous le redis on a
fraîchement les journalistes je vous dis
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce
qu'ils font des passes en 60 pieds pour
un oui pour un non
jouer deux jours et ils font mal aux
vrais journalistes
la vraie journaliste un vrai travail et
qu'il ya des journalistes formidable
c'est long c'est tous ces mecs-là qui
font des articles pour faire des [ __ ] à
cliquer encore voilà
eh ben je vous le dis ça fait beaucoup
de mal oh mais tu tournes ici ça vous
fait mal c'est pas tes pmp ça va très
bien ça cartonne
moi si je vais vous donner un voilà un
conseil ne vous occupez pas de nous
franchement on écrivait plus rien sur
nous on s'en tape total
vous voulez écrire sur nous pour faire
du buzz et pour faire des clips donc là
ils vont créer leur sphère d
des papiers sur la ma réponse et voilà
ça va continuer comme si je t'ouvre
sacré deux mondes - qui suit la ddt
seulement depuis un an le monde ou ceux
qui participent
ceux qui ont vu l'émission est ce qui me
fait ça oui les messieurs parce que même
nous qui avons participé mais on a
manqué ce qui s'est passé allons un peu
plus loin en fait pourquoi parce que
comme vous vous recevez le star
internationale et mondiale
en fait j'ai des verts il fallait
trouver quelque chose sur l'émission
free a bien quelque chose évidemment pas
de bienveillance et oui ce fait ils
étaient tous dégoûtés hier soir qu'il
soit là peut-on en ukraine dont le bail
a que nous qui l'avons inventé les donc
merci éventuellement réagir mais
effectivement on n'a pas compris ce
qu'elle disait pascal communiqué - avec
vous qu'avec ils sont partenaires
s'attendent en mai ils étaient
constamment tourné vers lui mais bon ça
c'est vraiment le sujet alors on va on
voit là on voulait rouler parfait je
vois ce qu'on pense et téléspectateurs
[Musique]
voilà bon après si le téléspectateur
donc forcément on a 90 % il y en a douze
camps sécurité choqué quand même c'est
voilà donc mon nom jadis ceux qui ont
suivi
à partir du moment où on a suivi des
missions peut pas être chaud mais c'est
pas possible